the bigger your house is remember when
you had an apartment yep I do back in
the day back in the day yeah and you
didn't have a bunch of stuff nope you
had like very limited stuff yeah now you
got a big house and you got a lot of
stuff with a garage too but with the
garages I've been in which is kind of
filled up with stuff as well do your
cars fit in your garage anymore they do
now we uh recently very recently just
made the decision to go hard and clear
it out yeah if you put limitations on
yourself it can actually increase your
efficiency if you set yourself up with a
types tight schedule it can drive your
Tempo it can drive your pace if you give
yourself unlimited time if you give
yourself unlimited resources you're
going to use all those resources you're
going to use all that time